my promise to you is that by the end of
this podcast episode you are going to
have Fierce clarity about how you can
create better content Stand Out amongst
the competition and ultimately get more
views on your content and I know that's
a bold promise but truly those things
are accessed on the other side of
writing better titles and this came
about recently when we started to
actually expand our team at think media
and I realized that one of the skill
sets that we need to perpetuate amongst
our team is the ability to write great
titles now uh lately we've been
uploading around 10 videos per week on
our think media podcast Channel and our
main channel so we're writing a ton of
titles so not only the ability to write
great titles but also the skill set of
writing them consistently is something
we really needed to develop internally
so I wanted to release some information
and really train our team so I actually
shared an Insider document inside of our
slack thread and I just thought hey how
cool would this be to share it with you
our think media podcast Community
because we've now published thousands of
videos some have done well some have
done not as well and we've really
distilled down 10 things that we
consider when not just coming up with
titles But ultimately coming up with
even video topics themselves and these
this information is going to work in any
Niche it'll apply to whatever kind of
content you're creating and we're going
to break this across two episodes so I'm
going to talk about five in this episode
and then five in the next and so let's
ultimately Dive Right into this so
here's what we think about at think
media when we are kind of reviewing or
grading or determining is this title
good or not and does this title include
almost all or at least some of these
things and number one is is the title
benefit driven does it have features and
benefits one of the problems that
um business owners content creators and
marketers oftentimes make is they
actually just focus on the features and
not also the benefits you know when you
think about if you're selling a car like
the feature might be that you have power
seats but the benefit of power seats is
you're not going to have back pain
you're going to be more comfortable it's
ultimately going to be more pleasurable
when you're driving the vehicle you know
there are features that's usually the
facts about something and then the
benefits are what it's going to do for
you so here's an example of a think
media title from a video that Heather
did with Rob from vid IQ and here's the
title these colors are proven to get you
more views on YouTube
so kind of the features are like use
these colors in your thumbnails
okay so that's that's good that's like
the fact of it but what is the result
that that's going to get me well that's
actually features and benefits in the
title like use these colors and there's
a little bit of mystery there but
ultimately when you do it'll result in
more views here's another example from
our friend Aaron on demand who's
actually a part of our 21 video tips
series and if you haven't actually
accessed that it's totally free you got
to check it out at 21videotips.com but
uh she wrote a title talking about the
vid IQ software and she said this get
more views and save time with this
YouTube Tool vid IQ tutorial
so what's the benefit she actually leads
with the benefit which is what the
viewer wants more what they want is the
result they want views they want to save
time with what with a tool that's now a
feature and then vid IQ itself now if
you're already kind of problem or
solution aware then maybe you already
want to learn about vid IQ but a lot of
people don't necessarily know what the
tool is yet so this is why it's really
powerful to to try to include both or
actually benefits are oftentimes much
more powerful than features because I
want more views I want to save time oh
there's a tool to do it okay now I'm
getting educated about this tool here's
a title from our friend and student
benezotti from keto camp and he said
keto diet plan for beginners 15 things
you must know and so ultimately
I think I'm Gonna Learn 15 things about
a diet plan that I'm interested in right
so the diet plan is the feature
um and and then there's a little bit of
mystery which we'll discover later
because I don't know what the 15 things
are but I'm sensing that those are maybe
going to be some benefits or maybe more
features so consider when you're writing
your next title how can it be benefit
driven this was again one of the tips
that I was sharing with our team and if
it lacks that that benefit sauce that
benefits Sizzle I'm like man we got to
power this title up number two unique
and fresh and I wrote I told our team
this this is actually more challenging
for us now because of our history and
because of how many videos WE Post
so the challenge and whether you're just
starting and if you haven't even posted
videos you got to keep in mind that
there is more competition than ever
before
um there is more people posting content
than ever before and that shouldn't be
discouraged discouraging but we should
be aware of it and that's also one
reason to really stay connected with us
because we're here to just help you
stand out and by writing unique and
fresh titles that are a little bit
different unique a little bit fresh you
know they kind of have a something you
haven't seen before something you
haven't heard before and you may be
under the misconception or myth that man
everyone has done this this has already
been done but the truth is no there's
there's always a fresh angle on
something there's always fresh language
there's a fresh kind of positioning of
it so I'm just asking our team like hey
man how can we make this unique and
fresh and I think the biggest tips here
are trying to use fresh words like
beware of tired language or language
that's played out like language just
that's just been used a lot and so
what's the solution here is try to use
vocabulary
we'll try to grow your vocabulary and to
do so use tools one of the best ways to
grow your vocabulary is actually to
become a reader you know those who read
their vocabulary goes up because you're
just exposed to new and fresh language a
couple books I like are words that sell
and phrases that sell these are classic
books more than 6 000 entries to help
you promote your products services and
ideas now you can also Google here's
some things if you you can check those
books out we'll list them in the show
notes but if you want to just tap into
some free resources Google power words
or creative words or unique adjectives
and just look at lists that are online
to try to Power Up titles with some
unique language that is different than
maybe just the average title you're
seeing out there number three speaks to
desires and Ambitions of viewers and so
when you're writing powerful titles you
want to think about what are the desires
of the viewer and what are the Ambitions
of of the viewer and a really good rule
of thumb in any online business any
online YouTube channel especially in
education but even in entertainment
entertainment is the big three and if
you've never heard about these The Big
Three are the best really three niches
for creating a solid online brand
business YouTube channel and it's health
wealth and relationships
and when you think about health health
is of course how to lose weight how to
gain muscle but it's also how to
overcome chronic pain how to get to
sleep at night how to have more energy
and wealth would be how to make money
save money but how to build your
retirement account
minimalist living uh you know crypto
investing stocks relationships how to
have vibrant relationships dating
marriage recovery after divorce all
these types of things now you might say
but Sean might my Niche actually isn't
in one of those big three here's my
challenge to you when marketing and I
know you probably don't think of
yourself as a marketer you don't need to
think of yourself as a marketer but
here's what we're doing when we are
writing titles we are marketing our
videos right we are positioning our
videos in the best way possible to get
someone to click on them to be
interested in the content you gotta
learn marketing like so what you want to
think about is when presenting your
products Services content videos people
joining your course people joining your
list people like when you're presenting
any of that tapping into health wealth
or relationships and things related to
that is going to help
and people want to click on it here's
what I mean
uh if you can say that this video is
going to save you time that's ultimately
Health you're gonna have more peace
you're gonna have more peace of mind if
this video is ultimately going to give
you more energy again these are the
Ambitions people want these are the
deeper things they want they want more
energy they want more time they want
more peace of mind if this video is
going to save you money so this is why a
lot of DIY channels or something how to
do something DIY is a way of doing
something do it yourself that'll save
you money so the deeper motivation if
you're thinking about what are the
deeper motivations the deeper desires
the deeper Ambitions of your viewers you
know how to save if by having more time
it might be so that you can spend it on
your relationships so just try to speak
to the deeper desires and Ambitions of
your viewers and as I was sharing this
internal document with our team I was
like okay are we aware of and connected
to what our viewers want the most
one of the things we say all the time
here at think media is the creator who
understands the viewer best wins
understands what what are the viewers
desires and Ambitions what are their
biggest problems what keeps them up at
night
and so here's an example from Larry uh
Chung who's a chartered financial
analyst actually he was a part of one of
our challenges at think media incredible
story in in a short time it's only been
a matter of months and he's almost to a
hundred thousand subscribers but here's
one of his videos uh Ty and one of his
video titles very rich here's what it is
is it possible to live off dividends
question mark
a guide to Dividend growth investing to
get rich
so it's a little bit of a longer title
but his video for him is one of his top
videos it's got maybe almost 100 000
views
so is it possible to live off dividends
this is another kind of tip for titles
you can lead with a question that's a
question that not only that that the
viewer is curious about and then it it
promises a payoff to that this is a
guide to Dividend growth investing
there's kind of a keyword in there too
and some people try to say search is
dead I assure you it is not because you
can do both in terms of kind of being
clickable and also searchable in terms
of Google and the YouTube algorithm and
then of course the ambition is to get
rich too so there's a lot happening in
that title and
um that's a way of thinking about
desires and Ambitions now this again
Works in any Niche so I looked up a
gaming channel and here's the title max
weapon level in three games double
exclamation mark the new fastest way to
level up guns in Warzone so that's a
Call of Duty video very specific thing
here's how you can level up your guns in
just three games what are the desires
and Ambitions of your viewers every
viewer has a desire or ambition and it
may be to be entertained it may be to
surprise to be surprised of course you
know here at think media we think the
best and most practical way to really
build your influence your brand and earn
income is to is to be teaching something
is to be answering specific questions
solving problems because entrepreneurs
solve problems for a profit so think
about how can you speak to the desires
and Ambitions of you viewers next
the title should call out a specific
audience
now remember you don't need all of these
but if you can have some of these
these will power up your titles
so here's an example I did a video
recently and here's the title was an
urgent warning for all content creators
that is a specific audience if you don't
identify as a content creator you're not
going to click on that video great
that's actually a good thing here's a
here's a title from Jay Shetty he said
if you're an introvert watch this
great if you're not identifying with the
word introvert if you're not if that
doesn't like leap out to you well then
you're probably not going to click but
if you go oh that's me it it's it's like
a magnet that pulls in
a specific audience this is why this is
powerful when you actually call out a
specific audience it of course it's
going to eliminate a lot of people that
are potentially clicking but you're
gonna you'd be surprised you end up
going to be performing better when you
Niche down the audience in the title
because it's so strongly resonating with
a particular type of person here's a
title from mm personal styling
how to hide a larger stomach do's and
don'ts apple shape this was one of their
higher performing videos
and there's a lot of there's a lot of
details in there of course okay with
fashion or with
um you know style I'm going to hide a
larger stomach what if I have an apple
shape it's a particular body type so
rather than just going so generic in
your titles and in your content think
about how you could be much more
specific by calling out a specific
audience one more example
my top 20 first time home buyer tips
first time home buyer advice and so
again if you are an investor it's not
for you you're not a first-time
homebuyer if you're not even interested
in buying a home you're not going to
watch that but you're calling out a
specific audience so think about how you
can call out a specific audience in your
content and then finally number five uh
agitate a problem the viewer has and
make a promise to solve it so one angle
you can go is speaking really to the
desires and Ambitions another angle you
can go is speaking to problems and
making a promise to solve it and so
here's an example from Twin home experts
black mold
how we get rid of mold in under three
minutes man what a title here's my
problem black mold I want to get rid of
it great and then there's some speed
there's a time frame added there and
it's a fast time frame man I gotta check
this out I got a problem and I want to
fix it and I want to fix it quick strong
title here's another example from
retirement 360 blueprint
Tax Strategies for high income earners
to help reduce taxes
so we're stacking these because there's
specific audience is high income earners
Tax Strategies is more of a feature like
I don't wake up any given day and I'm
like you know I just need some more Tax
Strategies like I mean I actually I
actually do wake up thinking about that
a lot of times but I think about the why
it's not I need the feature of Tax
Strategies it's because I want to reduce
I want to help reduce my tax bill my tax
payment so ultimately he's stacking them
all together and notice how this is
possible in just one sentence Tax
Strategies for high income earners to
help reduce taxes you're you're hitting
the problem and you're also making a
promise to solve it check out this one
from All Out Blitz fishing
Crab Pot Basics how to set up your Crag
crab pots to catch more crab right and
so maybe you just want your new to crab
potting crabbing and and you want the
basics and then the promise to solve it
is here's how to set it up and here's
the benefit not just I'm going to teach
you how to use your Crab Pot but what's
the ultimate desire you have I want to
catch more crab and so I want to you to
consider how could you use these titles
of course in your next video and these
are some of the things that we use as
triggers to remind us at think media are
our titles scoring well in any of these
categories they don't have to be in all
of them or are they underperforming are
they doing this because these are the
type of power levers that you can add to
your titles on your next video to get
more views and get more impact and by
the way one of the resources we get so
much positive feedback about in the
think media Community is our 2 tube at
our YouTube starter kit and specifically
we have what's called our 15 title
formulas so while you're learning this
skill of actually implementing these
things this may not come natural to you
the reason people love this is because
it's just a copy paste document if you
just want to literally copy paste 15 of
the best title formulas that we've
discovered posting thousands of videos
working with thousands of clients and
resource researching the best performing
content on YouTube that's available for
you we have it on a special price at
tubestarterkit.com very affordable
resource and so uh in recap benefit
driven number one talk about features
and benefits number two unique and fresh
number three speaks directly to the
desires and Ambitions of viewers number
four calls out a specific audience and
number five it agitates a problem the
viewer has and makes a promise to solve
it
[Music]